and the stronger the emotional reaction
you have to some experience in your life
the higher the emotional quotient the
more you pay attention to the cause and
the moment the brain puts all of its
attention on the cause it takes a
snapshot and that's called the memory so
long-term memories are created from very
highly emotional experiences what
happens then is that people think
neurologically within the circuitry of
that experience and they feel chemically
within the boundaries of those emotions
and so when you have an emotional
reaction to someone or something most
people think that they can't control
their emotional reaction it turns out if
you allow that emotional reaction it's
called a refractory period to last for
hours or days that's called the mood say
to someone hey what's up so I'm gonna
move well why are you in a mood well I
had this thing happen to me five days
ago and I'm having one long emotional
reaction if you keep that same emotional
reaction going on for weeks or months
that's called temperament and if you
keep that same emotional reaction going
on for years on end that's called a
person trait
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
Michael Jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how to turn your negative
thoughts to positive ones enjoy
learning how to shorten your refractory
period of emotional reactions is really
where the work starts so then people
when they have an event what they do is
they keep recalling the event because
the the emotions of stress hormones the
survival emotions are saying pay
attention to what happened because you
want to be prepared if it happens again
turns out most people spend 70 percent
of their life living in survival and
living in stress so they're they're
always anticipating the worst case
scenario based on a past experience and
they're literally
out of the infinite Potentials in the
quantum field they're selecting the
worst possible outcome and they're
beginning to emotionally embrace it with
fear and their conditioning their body
into a state of fear do that enough
times body has a panic attack without
you you can't even predict it because
it's programmed subconsciously so then
you say to the person why are you this
way
and they'll say I am this way because of
this event that happened to me 15 or 20
years ago and what that means from
biological standpoint is that they
haven't been able to change since that
event
so then the emotions from The Experience
tend to give the body and the Brain A
Rush of energy so people become addicted
to the rush of those emotions and they
use the problems and conditions in their
life to reaffirm their limitation so at
least they can feel something so now
when it comes time to change you say the
person why are you this way well every
time they recall the event they're
producing the same chemistry in their
brain and body as if the event is
occurring firing and wiring the same
circuits
and sending the same emotional signature
to the body but what's the prevalence
behind that well your body is the
unconscious mind it doesn't know the
difference between the experience that's
creating the emotion and the emotion
that you're creating by thought alone so
the body's believing it's living in the
same past experience 24 hours a day
seven days a week 365 days a year and so
then when those emotions influence
certain thoughts and they do and then
those thoughts create the same emotions
and those same emotions influences
saying thoughts now the entire person's
state of being is in the past so then
the hardest part about change
is not making the same choices you did
the day before period and the moment you
decide to make a different Choice get
ready because it's going to feel
uncomfortable it's going to feel
unfamiliar if there's going to be some
uncertainty why does it feel so
uncomfortable is it because of the the
the neurons that fire together wire
together so I've there's like an
easiness to that Loop just because
literally and you've talked very
eloquently about this the way that the
neurons connect in the brain how rapidly
I've seen you show footage of how
rapidly those connections happen which
is pretty incredible is is that what
makes it so discomforting for people
I think that I think that the bigger
thing is that we we keep firing and
wiring those circuits they become more
hardwired so there you have a thought
and then the program runs but it's the
emotion that follows the thought if you
have a if you have a fearful thought
you're going to feel anxiety the moment
you feel anxiety your brain's checking
in with your body and saying yeah you're
pretty anxious so then you start
thinking more corresponding thoughts
equal to how you feel
while the redundancy of that cycle
conditions the body to become the mind
so now when it comes time to change
the person steps into that River of
change and they make a different choice
and all of a sudden they don't they they
don't feel the same way so the body says
well you've been doing this for 35 years
you're going to just stop feel suffering
and stop feeling guilty and stop feeling
shameful and you're not going to
complain or blame or make excuses or
feel sorry for yourself well the body's
in the unknown so the body says I want
to return back to familiar territory so
the body starts influencing the mind and
it says
start tomorrow you're too much like your
mother you'll never change this is going
to work for you this doesn't feel right
and so if you respond to that thought
as if it's true that same thought will
lead to the same Choice which will lead
to the same behavior which will create
the same experience which will produce
the same emotion rule number two choose
how to respond to negativity with Tom
bilyeu my brain somehow finds ways to
trick me and keep me unmotivated and
negative all the time it's really
depressing to be like this and stuck in
a rut if you could help me overcome this
curse of negativity I truly appreciate
it and thanks a million for your efforts
all right
homie when I say I have the Silver
Bullet for this one this this is the
magic Genius answer that people were
looking for in the other one here it
goes
you do not need to think that you are
anything special it is absolutely okay
for you to be hopelessly average
why
to meet the most powerful thing that you
could believe about yourself is that
you're the average human now why I
actually think it is less powerful for
you to think that you were above average
because to think that you were above
average means that you are valuing
yourself for being better than people
it's a super vulnerable position to be
in because you will inevitably meet
people who are better than you and what
do you do with your ego then then it's
really crushing you thought you were the
man and now you encounter somebody
that's better than you they slap you
around they outperform you they dunk on
you whatever and now whoa like you've
got to rebuild and Claw your way back
versus
saying the following
the average human is the ultimate
adaptation machine
as a species
humans have chosen to respond to
cultural and environmental cues so we do
not come pre-programmed like a horse
that comes out of the womb 10 minutes
later is ready to rock and roll it's
running around doing all the things that
a horse can do like human on the other
hand has this huge period of development
after birth where we cannot take care of
ourselves we can't walk can't hold our
own head up our pants it's crazy
but what that does is it allows us to
drink in this the environment that we're
born into and adapt so the average human
is the ultimate adaptation machine
therefore being the average human means
you're a learner that's it you're not
exceptional so you're not putting any of
your psychology your
um self-worth your pride into being
better than somebody else
it all comes down to valuing yourself
for being the learner so hey cool you
wasted a bunch of time at school no
reason to hide from that it was a waste
we're not going to repeat the mistake
but we learn so you've got the
self-awareness to see that it was a
mistake now it's just like what do you
want to do what do you want to get great
at because if you apply yourself even if
you're not good yet
you can get good
how do I know that because you're the
average human and the average human is
the ultimate adaptation machine this is
all about discipline focused energy into
acquiring a skill set so what I call the
only belief that matters when you
believe that time and energy directed at
something through deliberate practice
will actually make you better at that
thing
now all of a sudden it's like I can get
good at anything if I apply myself and
now all of a sudden your behaviors align
with your belief that's why that belief
matters so much because if you don't
think you can get better at something
then why would you apply any time and
energy to it and if you don't apply time
and energy to it then you really won't
get any better so it becomes this Loop
of well I believe I can get better
therefore I try therefore I actually get
better therefore I try harder and you
get in this virtuous cycle
this is hugely important that is one of
those things that will govern the rest
of your life you value yourself for
learning getting better at something and
applying yourself everything else will
take care of itself because you just
keep applying yourself don't make
excuses don't be asked yourself if you
wasted time you wasted time don't spend
your time beating yourself up over it
because we only do and believe that
which moves us towards our goals right
we talked about that earlier so we're
gonna do and believe that which moves us
towards our goal and in this case that
is the belief that we can get good at
anything now there's an incredible quote
I love this quote so much
you can't make a racehorse out of a pig
but you can make a really fast Pig
your life can be the answer to what does
a fast pig look like that is certainly
what my life is all the success that
I've had in my life is not because I was
gifted at any one thing when I left for
college my mother quietly assumed I was
going to fail my best friend assumed I
was going to marshmallow my way through
life when I asked my father-in-law for
his Blessing to marry his daughter he
said no
and yet I went on to be successful to
earn my father-in-law's respect
um
not because they misidentified me
because they didn't they were right
but because I developed Drive I got the
only belief that mattered and I finally
realized that
humans are meant to grow and get better
at something and I just have to apply
myself and the same is true for you
decide what you want to get good at and
go after it with everything you've got
and that my friends is how you overcome
negativity alright guys do not let
negativity hold you back you were in
complete control Victor Frankel was in a
concentration camp he said between
stimulus in response there is a gap you
choose how to respond in that Gap the
negativity will arise almost certainly
forever
but when that negative voice presents
itself how you respond is up to you also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number three is become aware
with Eckhart Tolle peace Banker asks
I have owned the audio version of The
Power of Now for over 10 years but I
feel that I still get stuck around my
pain body there must be something very
seductive about it as I feel I liked I
like I spend a lot of time in negative
thoughts like what's the point and
you'll never get past this so why even
try
which can lead to feelings of
hopelessness and depression I've read
that emotions generate chemical
compounds in the brain which can be
addictive like drugs so that it's
possible to be addicted to negative
thinking in a sense and I think I suffer
from that addiction do you have any
insights as to how to break free it is
true that negative thinking can be very
addictive
I from my point of view it is not caused
by the chemical that's generated in the
brain or they do not deny that the
chemicals in the body very often reflect
certain things that happen on the mental
emotional level
but what comes first the chicken or the
egg
so if you
if you become very angry of course there
are certain chemicals that are released
in the body and if you become peaceful
then they go the addiction is not in the
chemical or the door I don't deny that
there is a chemical component to
emotional states
but it is the addiction to negative
thinking
and then the addiction to negative
thinking is usually connected to the
pain body which is the emotional field
that feels
fed fueled by the negative thinking so
if who do with addiction means it feels
on some level it feels good if you're
addicted to something on some level it
feels good if you're addicted to alcohol
the drinking feels good while you drink
not afterwards but while you drink
so if you're addicted well who feel
to whom does it feel good
not to you
not to the physical body because the
physical body suffers
through it but to the pain body this
emotion loves to get more of the same
energy by generating further negative
thinking in your mind and it feeds on it
because it doesn't get enough food
through the drama in your relationship
either you don't have one or there's not
in all your partner doesn't cooperate
enough
so
how this
you are kiss kiss you are aware
of these negative thoughts that you
mentioned that are repetitive and happen
frequently you give two examples one is
you'll never get past this or why even
try and
uh what's the point it's another one and
they're probably others so so you are
aware of these thoughts but
it seems that you are not aware in the
moment that these thoughts arise you are
aware retrospectively after the thoughts
you realize or these are there was that
thought again
uh the question is whether there's
enough presence in you to be aware in
the moment or immediately after
a thought of that kind arises
to to notice it
to notice also its futility to notice
its repetitiveness to notice its
pointlessness
it's untruths
to notice that you you don't want it
because you don't want it when you
notice it you are the awareness and you
as the awareness don't want it the pain
what he wants it so the awareness has to
come in so that you break the link
between
your pain body
and your thought processes
that is the key is to sever the link
between your thought processes and the
pain body in order to savor the link
between those
that needs to be enough awareness
presence only the presence can sever the
link the presence comes in and so you
you no longer
the emotion is no longer controlling
your thought activity
that's the key
and that's the beginning of the end
of that
vicious circle
that otherwise will take over your life
so
what is needed
is for you to be there in the moments
these thoughts occur or immediately
after and then immediately look at the
thought and say that's again and do not
believe it
you know some of you and many of you
might know Byron Katie's work
and Byron Katie's work questions your
thoughts and that's a wonderful thing so
that you no longer believe every thought
that comes into your head what's the
point if you believe it so what's the
point
[Music]
it's not working anyway nothing works in
my life it's never never has anything
worked in my life be there when the
thoughts happen recognize
they are pointless they're futile
they're painful I don't want them I
don't need them they have no purpose
whatsoever
so Byron Katie approaches Thoughts by
asking is it true so whatever people say
is that true and in most cases say well
do you know it to be true there's no
point is that true yeah it's true do you
really know it to be true no I don't
know if there's no point or not
so it kind of uh diffuses the power of
thought Over You by asking the question
it kind of
it's like
taking the valve out of an inflatable
toy by asking do I really know the
thought is yeah
and you you pull out the stopper and it
goes
[Applause]
do I really know this to be no not
really so rule number four is become
self-controlled with Jay Shetty so from
a monk's perspective the greatest power
is to be self-controlled to be able to
train the mind and energy to focus it
exactly where you want it and when you
want it to be you are completely
detached and undeterred from external
ups and downs you're able to navigate
anything that seems tough challenging
fun excitement with the same amount of
being acropoised and balanced in
Equanimity without being too excited in
pleasure or being too depressed in pain
but knowing how to navigate every
situation to me that's great strength
and great power there's a beautiful
verse in the bhagavad-gita that says
that Detachment is not that you owe
nothing Detachment is that nothing owns
you and and I love it because to me that
summarizes Detachment in a way that it's
not usually explained usually people see
Detachment as being away from everything
actually the greatest Detachment is
being close to everything and not
letting it consume an own you and that's
real power and that's real strength how
many people do we know that have had
Fame and then that Fame has ruined them
so for me that definition of Detachment
is possible to practice even in the real
world rather than saying oh I'm just
gonna have a really simple life I'm Just
Gonna Have Nothing in life being able to
overcome ego being able to overcome Envy
being able to overcome jealousy being
able able to overcome the negative of
competitive State there's a positive
competitive State and there's a negative
competitive state today when people are
looking on Instagram or Facebook or
YouTube all you're looking at is oh
she's got that many likes or he got that
many likes she got engaged or he got
married or oh my God look at her body or
look at that and it's like that stuff's
destroying us inside Envy jealousy ego
greed to be able to have enough Clarity
to purify yourself of those things is
going to alleviate the the biggest
anxieties and depressions of our time
and mental health problems and and we
know that we know that because all the
mental health research today suggests
that things like isolation overexposure
we now can have more pain consumption in
one day because of what we're exposed to
than the pain we would have had in a
lifetime that's huge like that's
ridiculous to think that in one day
because of the media news and social
media we consume more negative than we
did in a lifetime for me being able to
have time energy and Clarity to focus on
self-purification
that is the best thing about being a
monk because you have that time
reflection and a process and an
environment that only allows you to
become more purified of those things and
rule number five the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is
understand how the mind works with sad
Guru
well
see the way uh the question is asked and
also the way normally it's addressed is
people think there is something called
as negative thought and positive thought
they want to remove the negative
thoughts and have only positive thoughts
where such people and I would ask them
to just experiment for uh 10-15 seconds
let them forcefully remove one thought
from their mind for example next 10
seconds
just don't think of a monkey
try not to think of a monkey for next 10
seconds you will see you will be full of
monkeys so what I am saying is this is
the nature of your mind because in this
mind all the three petals are throttled
there is no break there is no clutch
whatever you touch it will only go
faster in this kind of mind people have
been taught from moral teachers and
religious teachers do not think about
bad things well since then it's been a
full-time job
so there is no way you can handle the
mind like this this doesn't need any
great Enlightenment if you spend two
minutes with your eyes closed you will
realize you cannot do anything
forcefully with this mind
so I want to remove negative thoughts do
not ever go in this direction because
what you want to remove will become your
quality always you will be on it
so what should I do
the thing is this
without understanding the fundamental
mechanism of this mind because our mind
human mind is the most
sophisticated computer on the planet
even all the super computers have come
out of this
when this is the case is it not
important that we understand the
mechanics of how it functions one
simplistic aspect of how it functions is
there are no
subtractions and divisions in our mind
there is only addition and
multiplication
if you try to do something with it it
will say one more
if you try hard it will multiply into
many more in this mind you don't try to
identify what is positive what is
negative and try to remove it
first of all one needs to understand
this mind of yours this body of yours is
supposed to serve you
the life that you are is important body
and mind are vehicles that must serve us
if you sit in a vehicle it must go where
you want to go if it goes to its own
destination what is the point of such a
vehicle it's just a nuisance right now
most human beings are unfortunately
experiencing this fantastic possibility
of human mind as a nuisance as a
Troublesome thing
well this is the most beautiful thing
you have
it's just that you need to pay little
attention as to how it functions one
simple thing is this
first and foremost processes that's why
we put out this uh process called Isha
kriya this is to distance yourself from
your physiological and psychological
process
there is something called as you which
exists
this is not a composite of all your
thoughts and emotions and physiological
processes beyond that there is you if
you close your eyes even if you cannot
see anything you are still there
it is through the window of your eyes
that you are looking out but if you
close your eyes it doesn't mean that you
don't exist you still exist so beyond
your thought you still exist beyond your
emotion you still exist so that you the
life that you are this has to come into
your experience
why is it that you are not allowing that
to come into your experience which is
the most significant aspect of who you
are who you are right now the most
significant aspect is you and me are
alive right now this is it what I am
thinking what you're thinking is not the
important thing we are alive right now
that is the important thing so it is
important that you focus on this
fundamental sense of aliveness within
you and then you will see there is a
natural distance between you and your
thought process once there is a distance
between your psychological process and
your physiological process this is the
end of suffering because there are only
two kinds of suffering that human beings
go through physical suffering and mental
suffering once you create a little space
between you and your mind between you
and your body this is the end of
suffering this is something every human
being has to experience and know
otherwise thinking I will just remove
negative thoughts and I will have
positive thoughts all the best it's not
going to work 100 it's not going to work
because nobody can remove it they can
avoid it for some time so when negative
thoughts come you say ram ram Shiva
Shiva whatever you want but this is just
avoiding it's not gone the moment you
stop that it will pop back with great
force otherwise it will come back in
your dreams so it's very important first
of all you need to understand your anger
your resentment your fear your anxieties
the negativity that you generate
generally resentment anger
it is always directed towards somebody
but we need to understand this is
poisons that we are drinking and
expecting somebody else to die
fortunately life doesn't work like that
if I drink poison I die if I drink
poison you don't die so we need to
understand this when I say poison
today you can have yourself chemically
analyzed right now what is your blood
work what it says five minutes of
intense anger check your blood work and
see there will be lots of negative
elements in it literally you're
poisoning yourself
so do you want to poison yourself
definitely not now the very question is
coming from certain helplessness what
shall I do
don't do anything
just sit back and just concern yourself
with something which is a life process
maybe your heartbeat maybe your breath
maybe just a sensation of being alive
depending upon how sensitive or how
perceptive you are accordingly find
something it could be a sensation in the
body it could be breath it could be
heartbeat it could be anything something
which indicates life to you just pay
attention to that for some time slowly
you will see there is a distinction
between what is you and what you have
gathered which includes both your
physiological and psychological
possibility or mess whatever you made
out of it
so as you guys know entrepreneurship is
tough it's the hardest thing you're ever
going to do in your life and there's so
many ups and downs around the business
that if you lose your positivity if you
start to get Negative then it's going to
be really really hard to keep your
business going because you need to be
that Force you need to be that positive
person that's infecting others to go and
do this impossible thing that nobody
thought was possible to do right you
need to have that positivity because if
you give up everything crumbles so today
I'm going to talk about seven ways that
you guys can use to stay positive even
when there's craziness and crap
happening all around you
so number one is belief no surprise
coming for me it's important to believe
in what you're all about and believe in
the mission and belief breaks down to me
is believe in what you're doing so have
passion right whatever project you're
working on you need to believe in it you
need to have the passion behind that
project it's believe in yourself having
the confidence to know that you can do
this and believe that it's going to work
out to have the conviction to keep going
and to follow through at the end of the
day what really helps is remembering
your why what is the big thing that you
are trying to accomplish with your
business with your idea because that can
help you stay motivated because
sometimes you get so lost in the weeds
of the day-to-day grind that you forget
about the big purpose the big mission
that you're on and for me remembering
why I'm doing this what the reason is
behind something that can help you get
through those Hard Times those dark days
so believe and remember why you're doing
this
number two is create a great environment
it's super important that you have an
environment that makes you come alive
that builds you up that lifts your
spirits that makes you believe that you
are you know the best version of
yourself and so I'm filming here in my
office you can see some of the stuff
behind me right you've got Steve Jobs
here and Howard Schultz here and my
parents here and there's other famous
entrepreneurs on my wall I want to
create an environment that I walk into
and I feel enriched and I feel happy and
it's hard to walk in like I'm working
here this is my desk I'm working here
and I've got like these people looking
at me I walk into the room and I've got
these people looking at me and it
inspires me right and that's me like you
may look at that and say that's really
stupid I don't want to have those people
in my wall that's creepy to have these
big faces up on the wall whatever it is
right that helps me and so creating an
environment that makes you come alive
think about what's on the walls what's
on your computer what's on the phone
background what apps do you use right
like what's around you who are the
people in your life what books do you
read what are the videos that you watch
what are the things that are around you
that help build you to be the person
that you could be because you know the
feeling if you're around negative people
if you're watching the news all the time
you're gonna start feeling really
negative if you're surrounded by
positive things uplifting things
resources that build you up that give
you ideas that make you feel creative
that make you have confidence that's so
much better for you it's better for your
health it's better for the Creations
that you'll you'll put out and it's
better for the world and so don't make
your environment something that just
happens to you by accident consciously
create it for yourself so you've made an
environment that helps you be the best
version of you
number three is help someone it's really
hard to feel down to be negative to have
a bad attitude when you're helping
somebody else out and so a great way out
of the doldrums is to help somebody it
could be somebody in your business it
could be a customer could be a partner
it could be an employee it could be you
know A supplier but it could be somebody
on the street it could be the person
behind you you know in Starbucks pay for
their coffee right and just something
holding the door for somebody something
where they would appreciate it could be
a handwritten note to somebody it
doesn't have to cost you money it
doesn't have to cost you a lot of money
or any money it just takes a little bit
of time and a little bit of awareness
and appreciation to find somebody in
your life that you know or you you're
about to know to find a way to
contribute to them in some way that
makes them feel good and when you make
somebody else feel good naturally you
just make yourself feel good even going
on the comments of this video and
responding to some of the other people
who've left comments makes them feel
good right recognize them appreciate
them thank them for their insights that
will make them feel good but in that
process it makes you feel good too so if
you're ever feeling down or negative a
quick way out is to help somebody
number four is improve your habits just
like the environment that you're in is
super important so are the habits
because you are what you consistently do
so what do you consistently do do you
engage in negative habits do you engage
in things that bring you down or do you
engage in habits that are meant to build
you up so what does your morning routine
look like what does your evening routine
look like what does your schedule look
like on a day-to-day basis is it
something that helps build you up or do
you just fall into it by accident
because you're so rushed to get through
the day right if you don't have 10
minutes to spend on creating an ideal
schedule in life for yourself or 10
minutes in the morning to Center
yourself then you don't deserve to have
the great things you don't deserve to
have an amazing life right spend the
time you have 10 minutes to focus
yourself and so what are the habits that
you are doing consistently what does
your day look like consistently so for
me I wanted to have more greatness
around me right and so I put the habit
of watching the videos every day I made
the top 10 10 videos and espresso videos
for me selfishly because I wanted it I
wanted to be around these big name
entrepreneurs who've done big things and
I watch them and I get inspired because
it's so easy to be complacent it's so
easy to wake up and just fall back into
your usual habiting routine work here I
watched somebody doing something
thinking man I I gotta go out and do
something bigger myself and I need that
every day because I'm all pumped up and
excited today on Wednesday filming name
for you guys jacked up super excited
tomorrow I'm gonna wake up and it's
starting all over again so I need to
have something in my morning routine to
get me fired up again to help me push
beyond my safe comfort zone to something
that makes me do something that's new
and scary and different and exciting and
so what are your habits what do you do
consistently what is your morning
routine is it engineered
for you to be a success instead of you
falling into it by accident create
positive habits
number five is have accountability it
can be really hard to only be
accountable to yourself because you'll
tend to do the things that you just want
to do and not push yourself to where you
could go and I think as entrepreneurs
it's especially hard because we don't
have a boss right yeah you have a
customer who may be pushing you on a
deadline okay great you work hard to get
that deadline down but otherwise you
don't have a boss you get to make all
the decisions yourself there's nobody
pushing to say Hey you could do a lot
better and so having an accountability
partner having a mastermind group having
a place where you can share your goals
and have people hold you accountable to
them and even just putting it out in
public post on this video go to the
comments and say some of your goals and
what you want to accomplish within the
next month what do you have on your
radar what are you trying to accomplish
right even just posting it up makes you
feel a little bit more accountable and
that's important because you will tend
to let yourself down too much we won't
let other people down you'll show up for
that meeting you'll show up to go to
that gym class if somebody else is there
with you because they're channeling you
to be there you won't let other people
down nearly as much as you let yourself
down so use that to your advantage
and partner up with people and you can
help them too right this ties into the
other point about helping each other out
you can help them stay accountable on
their goals and if you know that you're
meeting this person next week and you
you haven't done the thing you said
you're gonna do you're more likely to
bust into higher gear to make sure you
get that thing done because you don't
want to let them down and so use that
hack to help you get the stuff done that
you need to get done have more
accountability
thank you
number six is be grateful and talk about
positive habits one of the things that I
do every day in in my team is we have a
private Facebook group where we talk
about three things that we're grateful
for every day so every day you log in
the Facebook and you have to add three
things that you're grateful for and it
may take you two minutes to do but it's
really hard to hold gratitude in your
mind and some negative or angry thought
and some of the things we you know are
grateful for they might be a big thing
like I might be grateful for hating I'm
grateful for Nina I'm grateful for my
parents grateful you know live in this
beautiful city have this life that I do
and some of them are more esoteric like
I'm grateful for the internet you know
I'm grateful that Alex brought me a
coffee today you know I'm grateful that
I have my own clothing line now I can be
grateful for a lot of different I'm
grateful there's a son shining on me
today that it's a beautiful day outside
right if you take a couple minutes not
just to write them down but to actually
feel it to feel the Gratitude to feel
the warmth of the sun to feel the love
of your mom to feel you know if you have
kids or pets or plants that you know
that you really love to feel that then
it's really hard to feel that gratitude
and be negative about something at the
same time it's really hard to hold that
in your head let me ask you guys one of
the things I'm thinking about doing is
doing a live stream every weekday
morning
maybe 10 o'clock I haven't figured it
out for 10 minutes just expressing
gratitude for me to share three things
that I'm grateful for the same three
things that I make my team do but then
for you guys also to share some of the
things that you're grateful for you can
join me on the journey and join me in
the ritual that every day we do this
together and share the things that we're
grateful for I'm thinking about doing it
as a live stream in the channel really
curious to see what you guys think if
you like that idea or not because it's
had a profound impact on me if you look
at the research around happiness it
always comes down to gratitude it's not
about the money you have or the car you
have or the job you have or any of that
stuff it's about being grateful for what
you do have that's consistent across all
the research and so it's had a big
impact on me it's had a big impact on my
team you know I'm always looking at how
can I help you guys how can I help the
entrepreneurs out in Michigan or Ohio or
Australia wherever you guys all are from
that I can't connect with you one-on-one
to do this thing where we spend 10
minutes together expressing our
gratitude for the day let me know do you
guys want to do it is that interesting
to you do you feel it's too fluffy BS
Hokey Pokey not interested let me know
because if enough you want to do it then
then I just might do it so curious leave
that in the comments below so that's
number six be grateful
and then number seven is live your one
word it's super important that you know
what you stand for and that you start
living it because chances are if you are
unhappy if you're not satisfied with
what's going on if you are a negative
constantly it's because too many things
in your life are not aligned with what
your one word is all about and your one
word is finding for me it's believe but
for you it's likely something else it's
figuring out what you stand for as a
human being what is the most important
core value to you it's what my book is
all about what is the most important
core value to you and then how can you
build a business and a life around it so
that is congruent for you so that doors
open more easily for you so that
decisions are made more easily
understanding who you are and what you
stand for makes everything a lot
smoother and easier compared to just
reacting to things and reacting to other
people's agenda set your own and so
again if you are unhappy with something
if you're not satisfied it's likely
because too many of the things in your
life
are out of congruency with your one word
you're doing too many things that are
not aligned with who you are as a human
being and so understanding what it is
that you stand for and then building a
life and a business around it really
dramatically improves the chance of you
being happy positive but also having a
huge impact and creating something maybe
even way bigger than you thought you'd
be able to create so live your one word
and if you need help trying to figure
out what that is you can always
pre-order the book it's a great read I
guarantee but even if you don't
understanding who you are what you stand
for and living a life around it will
dramatically change your life negativity
is a multiple of four to seven times
more powerful than positivity
so think about that if I say something
out loud it's 10x if it's negative it's
four to seven times more powerful so
when I say negative things out loud it's
40 to 70 times more likely that that
will happen or cause a result that won't
be good for me than if I just didn't say
anything
so as we were going into our second year
at Alabama we were going into our first
year at Florida State and we were
ultimately going into our second year at
the University of Georgia we made a bet
what if we could just get our players to
not say stupid things out loud
what if we could just do that not teach
any element of positive thinking but
eliminate conversations about the heat
complaining about coaches complaining
about circumstances complaining about
situations verbalizing negativity but we
weren't going to lie to them and say hey
be positive we just taught them the data
and then what we did was some of the
things that you you noticed in the book
the stories in and around negativity are
incredible
tell us some Bill Buckner was one that
took my breath away
so so Billy Buckner who just passed away
recently was an incredible eight-time
goal to go have a great baseball player
for the Boston Red Sox
well he made a mistake in sports that
would be one of the biggest sport
bloopers in history and in 1986 he let
the game-winning runs score on a ground
ball through his legs that ultimately
would give them Mets the World Series
now I was just watching an ESPN E60
Jeremy shaft story and I saw an
interview that was done in 1990 that
resurfaced in 1995 where Buckner was
interviewed 12 days before the World
Series and he said you know the dreams
are to win
you know to win the World Series and the
nightmare would be for me to let the
game-winning run score on a ground ball
through my legs
you know and then ultimately that's
exactly what would happen now by saying
that out loud what did he do he didn't
make it happen but he increased the
probability
and this is what I want people to
understand your internal thoughts are
all over the place I want to push on
that yeah do you think that he makes it
more likely because it's going to subtly
influence his behavior or because you're
talking to some magical deity that then
says well you said it and so I'm going
to make it happen I think that what he
did is a subconscious plant by
verbalizing it and knowing that it's ten
times more powerful he's planting it in
his subconscious he's not he doesn't
want it to happen but it becomes
something that's ultimately on his mind
and he gave it more power by verbalizing
it and then wasn't there somebody that
said I I worry that I'm gonna retire and
die at 40 of a heart attack right so so
Pistol Pete Maravich a basketball player
I'll give you two other examples but but
he was interviewed at 26 years old and
he said you know I don't want to play 10
years of pro basketball and die at the
age of 40 of a heart attack
well he played 10 years of pro
basketball in Pasadena California died
of a heart attack at 40. there's another
great story that I saw from a magazine
called Success Unlimited in 1973 a guy
is hired to fix a refrigerated boxcar in
back of a train he goes into the train
he panics gets himself locked inside the
boxcar so now he's pounding on the door
there's nothing to do he starts to panic
and thinks he's going to freeze to death
he finds a pen he starts writing down
Tom what's going through his mind and he
writes down I'm becoming colder as
people one of the things we do to
ourselves is Observe and Report I'm not
playing well I'm having a bad day we're
having a bad quarter my marriage isn't
going well we observe and report still
colder now he writes nothing to do but
wait half asleep I could hardly write
finally he says these might be my last
words and I'll show you the article they
open up the boxcar many hours later and
they find him and he's dead but the
temperature inside the boxcar was 56
degrees that's so crazy the freezing
apparatus was broken there was plenty of
air in the boxcar there was no physical
reason for his death the best they could
say is somehow he talked himself into
dying and as you know the book covers
the psychogenic death in and around the
Korean War when the Korean War one-third
of All American pows died and they said
that one of the things that was done in
the POW camps was the negativity they
manufactured articles about the United
States being bombed they withheld all
positivity they didn't give them any
mail believe it or not there are like
regulations for POW camps throughout the
world and ultimately they filled up
these healthy American soldiers with all
this doubt uh a priest would end up
calling it give up itis and healthy
American soldiers over a period of days
would walk over to a corner sit down and
die of broken hearts
so negativity is the most powerful thing
we're combating look at our politics
today a positive message versus a
negative message it's no no chance have
you ever read men search for meaning I
haven't read that oh my God you're gonna
love it so man search for meaning Victor
Frankel's oh yes yes yes it's actually
in multiple if I remember right he was
in five different concentration camps
yes and ultimately
um he says that he you could tell within
72 hours when someone was going to die
because they would give up and he said
once they gave up then it was a 72-hour
clock they no longer knew why they were
fighting and and they would just die and
he was like but the people that kept a
mental image of what they were suffering
for like what it was they were going to
do once they got out for their family
for whatever
he said that they would push through and
it just I mean look there's obviously a
million and one reasons to die in a
concentration camp but the fact that
even in the concentration camp they
could go I'm 72 hours a week and pay get
right because we've seen that person
give up right that's just crazy to me
well and and I just think when when I
think about being seven years old and
the Tacoma golf and country club and
walking off the golf course and my dad
you know everybody call him Mr positive
and this and that but In fairness to my
dad when he was raised and he was
teaching the only thing was positive and
negative so if you weren't negative you
had to be positive
but that just never made sense to me and
if we could just learn how to not be
negative how to not externalize negative
then ultimately that would help them
more than ever trying to be told to be
positive your sense of feeling like the
effort is worth it begins and ends with
how encouraging supportive and kind you
are to yourself you have to become aware
of it and you have to realize that
sometimes like the way you talk to
yourself like believe it or not it does
impact us and whether we want to admit
it or not I think sometimes people when
they're feeling so down about themselves
they have a hard time admitting that
something in their life is going wrong
because they just are they're already
feeling so low that the idea of even
having something bring them even down
lower like scares the hell out of them
right yeah so so let's let's break this
apart let's let's role play here okay so
let's say
um
you are uh what was the sport that you
played as a kid
I tried to play All Sports I wasn't very
good but I would say the the sport that
I was the most consistent with was
basketball okay
so
little dog is on the basketball court
and
there's a foul and Doug is the uh person
that is selected to shoot the free throw
and little Doug steps up to the free
throw line
and then all of a sudden they call a
timeout
and you come running back to the huddle
what would be the most empowering
and encouraging and motivating
thing
that your coach or teammates could do or
say
in order to help you perform and feel
your best when you step onto that line
like I believe in you and you're gonna
make it I believe in you and you're
gonna make it you got this and then they
send you back into that game with a high
five
right how would that make you feel
little nine-year-old Doug
I'd feel pretty confident right now
how would little nine-year-old dog feel
if when you came back to that huddle and
you're about to go do this free throw
that
your teammates are like oh him he's a
piece of sh have you he screws
everything up are you kidding me what
we're gonna whoa oh my god well I he
shouldn't be the one that does
how would that make little dog feel
it would probably obviously make me feel
like I'm not gonna make the shot so why
even bother correct
what you say to yourself matters
and we understand that
from a common sense perspective
but somewhere along the line we have all
stopped saying
you're gonna make it you got this and
we've started saying you're a piece
you're not good enough why even bother
and when you send yourself into a
conversation into a presentation into
even typing up an email
when you start your day
by saying I look terrible
I screwed up again yesterday I hate my
life
that's not going to motivate you to
change it
and so your sense of feeling like the
effort is worth it begins and ends with
how encouraging supportive and kind you
are to yourself
and you know we can also take this
little role play exercise and go well
let's say you missed the shot
and you come back to the sideline again
what could your coach say
or what would you want your coach to say
to help you get your head back in the
game and to brush off the mistake that
you just made
like you did your best dog you'll get
them next time like get back in there
and I have a feeling you're going to be
a positive contribution to the team yeah
that's right Shake It Off you did your
best you're gonna do it next time this
is that you win some you lose some let's
go now I need you to win some right I
believe in you
I think one of the the role plays that
we could maybe go into that I think is
pretty common with people is that they
acknowledge that they maybe have to
start talking to themselves to
themselves better but whatever they
start to say that's positive there's
this cognitive dissonance because they
just don't believe it right how do you
get somebody who for the last 10 to 15
years has just been completely
destroying themselves self-talk wise
begin to build some consistency with
that so now that becomes a new habit
that they're talking to themselves in a
more positive way and they actually
believe it instead of just saying it
this is a phenomenal and really smart
question if you have been trashing
yourself for 10 years you do have a
cognitive dissonance you don't even hear
it anymore because that negative you're
a piece you're not good enough you screw
everything up first began as something
you said then it became a belief your
brain started to align with the belief
and it starts to become your identity I
always screw things up and I want you to
hear me be loud and clear if you are on
social media and you ever go to the
Discover page on Instagram or on Tick
Tock or on any platform
that social media platform has put
together a mosaic of content that aligns
with everything that you consume in your
feed that's that social media platform
on the Discover page has assembled a
world on social media that looks just
like the stuff you're always looking at
your brain works exactly the same way
one of the reasons why it is so
important for you to identify how often
you are trashing yourself or being
pessimistic or you are being negative in
your attitude and unkind to yourself is
because as long as you think and speak
that
the Discover page of your mind presents
a world that matches to that negative
dialogue so that's why this is critical
the second thing that you need to do
because you're unconscious to it right
is there are two things that are going
to work because just trying to speak
kindly
often doesn't work because you have so
trained your mind that you think you're
not good enough that's saying I'm good
enough doesn't work because your brain
literally looks at you like who are you
talking to like I'm
because I can't be you so there's two
things that will help you based on the
research
the first one is journaling exercises
because there is something that happens
when you create a new habit where every
single morning before you look at that
social media
you open up a blank page and the way
that I
Journal is very simple
I always start by writing down five
things that I want
and I just let them flow through me what
are five things that I really want
and it might be something small it might
be that
you know I I want a really cool new pair
of sneakers it might be something big I
really want to feel happy
it might be something that is a feeling
like you know this this pandemic has
kicked the out of everybody I am I
am not immune from the feeling of
burnout or the feeling of languishing
the feeling of disconnection even from
self that that we can all feel when
you're isolated for this long and you're
remote for this long and you're stressed
out for this long and so allowing
yourself to write down five things that
you want I want to feel like myself
again
it allows the the things that you desire
to flow through the self-doubt and
through the negativity and through all
the crap that buries it and pushes it
down and it allows it to come to the
surface and the writing it down is
important because your mind is paying
attention
that discover page that your mind
creates pays attention to what you say
is important and if you begin a new
habit of just starting your day with a
blank piece of paper and writing down
five things that you want
every day can be the same things every
day it can be different things every day
you just allow yourself to do this you
will start to build the skill
of being connected
to what you desire you will start to
develop a skill
of tuning out the self-doubt and tuning
into what you want and this is really
important because your brain is paying
attention and it doesn't require you to
talk to yourself it just write it on a
piece of paper the next thing that
you're going to do step two is write
down why you want these things
because if you have a negative dialogue
Doug
you have for decades talked yourself out
of the things that you want
you have filled your heart and your soul
and your mind with all the reasons why
it's never going to happen
and so by starting every day with a new
habit write down five things that you
want and then write down why you want
these things you're developing a skill
of listening to what you want instead of
listening to the self-doubt
that's step one that's one thing that
you can do
to fight Decades of negative self-talk
the second thing that you can do is
every morning after you brush your teeth
add a high five in the mirror to your
reflection to your morning routine
that will have a shockingly powerful
impact on your negative self-talk
and the reason why it does is because
your brain watches you do it
and you only give a high five to
somebody that you believe in
that you're rooting for
that you're kind to and that you want to
see when
and what we've found based on
researching this simple habit adding a
high five to the mirror every single
morning you don't say a word as stupid
as it sounds just high five the mirror
what we have found after researching
this for 18 months and having a hundred
and fifty three thousand people from 91
countries do this for five days
is that it has a profound effect
on how you speak to and how you see
yourself because it is an action that
demonstrates to your brain
that you care about yourself and you
support yourself and so those are two
physical things that you can do
to start to shut down and fight back
against the critic that is programmed
into your head I'm never gonna argue
that we can subjectively control all of
our experience because there's some
things that just genuinely suck right
and when they and it's important to and
it's important to register those those
not so great events or terrible events
because they can drive us also you know
we can be driven from a place of anger
frustration and and you know revenge or
we can be driven from a place of you
know love gratitude and Etc I'm not here
to judge which one is better or worse
but the nervous system doesn't
distinguish between them so if you're
the kind of person that needs to you
know kind of budge yourself into
something great if you're the kind of
person that wants to do things from more
of a warm fuzzy feeling that's fine too
what I will say is this the ability to
tap into this dopamine reward system
which is activated anytime you're in
pursuit of something that's outside the
boundaries of your skin and literally
the boundaries of your body as well as
the reward system the serotonin oxytocin
system which is really about the things
that are contained within your own body
and immediate experience things like
gratitude and you know touch and comfort
and things like that with loved ones the
ability to tap into both is crucial now
you said something really important
which was well negative thoughts
negative thoughts what to do I don't
believe that it's very easy to suppress
negative thoughts however when you
realize that thoughts can be
deliberately introduced you can start
replacing negative thoughts with new
types of thoughts so you can always add
something in but when people start to
realize that thoughts are very much like
physical actions of reaching and picking
up a glass of water or taking a jog
around the ball block or typing an email
perfectly this is something I sometimes
do because I'm I you know I struggle to
do the perfect email not all my emails
are perfect but when I do one I make
sure that I I complete and I think okay
it's possible it's not because the email
being perfect is so important it's
because I want to remind myself that my
thoughts and my actions are essentially
the same the nervous system can organize
thoughts so for somebody that's
struggling
you know we have these examples like oh
they were really back on their heels or
they were so depleted no money and all
this stuff what are they gonna we we
have so many examples like that but in
trying to make it actionable it's really
about saying yep that's all true but I'm
going to introduce a thought which is I
made it through today I'm I made it
through today and that's actually worth
celebrating at a micro level so if you
can give yourself dopamine rewards in
small increments right you're not trying
to celebrate that you made it through
one day sometimes that's a huge feat but
most of the time you just want to dose
yourself with a little bit of that
internal release of dopamine you start
rewarding incremental steps and if
there's anything that your listeners
could take away from this whole thing
about dopamine and reward schedules and
being in movement it's reward
incremental steps in particular
incremental steps that are about forward
action so maybe that's writing an email
maybe that's
um maybe that's that run around the
block maybe that's something much
grander for you as you get better at
things right the stairs get further and
further away from one another because
you've achieved more success and so they
tend to be you have to take the rungs on
the ladder further apart so to speak
that's a time when you really need to
implement not only the dopamine rewards
but also those serotonin and oxytocin
rewards Etc so to make it actionable I
would say remember don't spend so much
time trying to suppress negative
thoughts if you need trauma therapy
pursue that with a professional but if
you have negative thoughts just remember
I can also introduce positive thoughts
the same way I can control running
around the block positive thoughts are
the equivalent of forward physical
action and if you reward them internally
you buffer yourself against the quitting
circuit this norepinephrine circuit we
were talking about before you are
building a stronger version of yourself
completely between your own ears and
some people say well that's silly it's
like you're saying oh I'm going to jump
up and down reward myself for doing
nothing no you're building the neural
circuits that reward that you can
control self-reward and in doing that
you can push through days and weeks of
effort consistently I don't mean
necessarily all-nighters but you can
push and push and push fundamentally the
most basic thing you got to do
especially at a time like covet is you
gotta every day have a couple of simple
practices one of those is every day you
got to feed your mind and when I say
Fiji Miami consciously seek out
something that's going to give you new
insight new inspiration new way of
looking things because otherwise today
the news follows you right it's in your
pocket and the news people are good
people but they're doing their job
what's their job make as much profit as
possible how do you get the most profit
get the most people to watch how you get
the most people to watch Fear if it you
know if it if it leads it leads is the
phrase they use in journalism right and
we've seen so much fear built up now
that most people have lost their faith
and you can't lose it fortunately it's
just the muscle that needs to be
regained but you have to fill your mind
you have to pursue it great ideas are
not going to interrupt you they have to
be pursued and the good news is today if
you get away from just the traditional
news you can go to podcasts like boss
babes you can go to different locations
you can get another perspective and you
can feed your mind but if you don't feed
your mind my original teacher was a guy
named Jim Rohn and he used to say Tony I
got a question for it he said what if
your worst enemy put sugar in your
coffee what's going to happen to you
when you drink that coffee so you're
gonna have sweet coffee he said you know
what if your family member your friend
Your Love by accident drops one drop of
strychnine what's gonna happen when you
drink their coffee is it you're gonna be
dead and he goes That's Right life is
sugar and strychnine so watch your
coffee like every day you got to stand
guard at the door of your mind
especially at times like this when
there's so much fear so you feed your
mind
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to start your day positively check
out this motivational speech right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there and perspective simply reminds us
to go to 50 000 feet on a bad day and
count our blessings perspective simply
reminds us that things could be a lot
worse